265 DAYS, WELL, I WOULD SAY, WE
ARE AT A TIPPING POINT, AMERICA
ON THE BRINK.
HERE NOW, FROM THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, DONALD TRUMP JR.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I’M DOING WELL.
SEE WHEN YOU’RE TRAVELING QUITE
A BIT, ON THE ROAD, BUSY.
>> WE ARE ON THE ROAD A LOT.
UNLIKE HUNTER BIDEN, WE WERE
ACTUALLY INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS
PEOPLE BEFORE MY FATHER TOOK
OFFICE.
WHEN HE DID, WE SAID, WE ARE NOT
DOING NEW DEALS GOING FORWARD.
TO GIVE ME A LITTLE EXTRA FREE
TIME.
>> Sean: I JUST HAPPEN TO KNOW
THAT’S TRUE BECAUSE I’VE KNOWN
YOU FOR MANY YEARS, LONG BEFORE
YOUR DAD GOT INTO POLITICS, AND
YOU WERE ACTUALLY WORKING IN A
REAL OFFICE.
STICK WITH WHAT I DID PLACE ME
WHEN YOU DID NOT GET PAID MONEY
UNLESS YOU MADE MONEY.
>> HARD TO BELIEVE.
>> Sean: YOU DID NOT GET TO
TAKE THE COMPANY JET.
YOU MENTIONED QUID PRO QUO JOE,
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
OKAY, WHITE PEOPLE, POLICE STUFF
WHITE PEOPLE TOO MUCH,
MINORITIES, TOO LITTLE.
LET’S TARGET MINORITY KIDS, COPS
MUST THROW THEM UP AGAINST THE
WALL.
LET’S LOOK AT, OH, MURDERS,
MURDER VICTIMS, MURDERERS.
THE AMMO, YOU JUST TAKE A
DESCRIPTION, YOU XEROX IT, YOU
PASS IT OUT TO ALL THE COPS,
THEY ARE ALL MALE MINORITIES.
WOW.
THEN HE GOES ON TO SAY, BECAUSE
THEY ARE ARRESTING ONLY ALL
MINORITY KIDS FOR MARIJUANA -- I
THINK KIDS OF OTHER RACES USE
MARIJUANA.
ALL THE COPS AND MINORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS BECAUSE THAT IS
WHERE ALL THE CRIME IS.
ALL OF IT.
>> LISTEN, THE BLOOMBERG
COMMENTS WERE TERRIBLE.
WE ARE NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THE POLICY.
JUST THE WAY HE SPOKE ABOUT
THOSE KIDS, THOSE PEOPLE.
IT WAS LIKE THEY WERE SUBHUMAN
TO HIM.
AGAIN, YOU CAN ARGUE ABOUT
POLICY, BUT THAT WAS DISGUSTING.
AND SO AGAIN, BILLIONS IN AD
SPENDING.
YOU SAW KATIE HILL COME OUT
TODAY.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG GAVE ME
$5 MILLION, IT ALLOWED ME TO
ADMIT MY CAMPAIGN, SHE LEFT
CONGRESS IN DISGRACE.
HE’S BEEN BUYING HIS WAY THROUGH
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
ONE THING THAT MIKE BLOOMBERG
CAN’T BUY’S PERSONALITY.
HE CAN’T BUY HEART.
HE CAN’T BUY THAT CONNECTION
WITH REAL PEOPLE THAT
DONALD TRUMP PASS.
I MEAN, DONALD TRUMP -- AGAIN, I
GET IT.
I UNDERSTAND THE IRONY THAT THE
BRASH BILLIONAIRE FROM
NEW YORK CITY COULD ACTUALLY
RELATE TO REAL PEOPLE.
BLUE-COLLAR AMERICANS ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
HE’S FOUGHT FOR THEM.
THEY SEE HIM COMPLETE SEE THE
RESULTS.
MIKE BLOOMBERG WILL NEVER HAVE
THAT DIRECT CONNECTION WITH
THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE HE DOESN’T
LIKE THOSE PEOPLE.
>> Sean: APPARENTLY.
IT’S NOT ABOUT STOP AND FRISK.
>> IS BASICALLY EVERYONE.
>> Sean: OF COURSE YOU WANT TO
GO INTO AREAS WITH A HIGHER
CONCENTRATION OF CRIME OR DRUGS
OR WHATEVER, VIOLENCE, WHATEVER
HAPPENS.
BUT THIS IS THE ULTIMATE IN
RACIAL PROFILING.
THESE COMMENTS ARE, NUMBER ONE,
FALSE.
NUMBER TWO, TARGETING AND
PROFILING IN A WAY THAT I NEVER
WOULD HAVE IMAGINED.
>> IT SEEMS VERY VIOLATING OF
JUST OUR BASIC RIGHTS.
AGAIN, IT IS NOT ABOUT THE
POLICY.
JUST LISTEN TO THE WAY HE SAID
IT.
IT WAS THE WAY -- HE DIDN’T
THINK OF THESE PEOPLE AS EVEN
HUMAN.
THEY WERE NOT EQUAL TO HIM AND
HIS, YOU KNOW, PEERS.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HIM AND DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP UNDERSTANDS REAL
PEOPLE.
HE UNDERSTANDS THEIR PROBLEMS.
THEIR ISSUES.
THAT IS WHY HE’S BEEN FIGHTING
FOR THEM.
>> Sean: DO YOU SEE THIS AS A
BERNIE SANDERS TO LOSE?
>> LISTEN, I SEE THE DNC DOING
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO SCREW
BERNIE SANDERS.
AND THAT IS A REALITY.
FOR THE LAST TIME THE DNC RIGGED
A PRIMARY, IT WORKED OUT GREAT
FOR US.
SO I’M GOING TO TRUST THEIR
TERRIBLE JUDGMENT AND LET THEM
RUN WITH IT.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THIS.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY ABOUT
BERNIE, HE’S GOT REAL PEOPLE.
I MEAN, HE HAS A MOVEMENT.
I DON’T AGREE WITH ANY OF THE
POLICIES.
I THINK THEY ARE DANGEROUS.
I THINK THEY ARE INSANE.
I WROTE ABOUT IT IN MY BOOK.
MY MOTHER ESCAPED A COMMUNIST
COUNTRY.
I GREW UP, I SPOKE A LANGUAGE, I
HAVE FRIENDS FROM COMMUNIST
CZECHOSLOVAKIA.
I WAITED AND THOSE BREAD LINES,
I CAN ASSURE YOU, THEY ARE NOT
AS GLAMOROUS AS BERNIE AND
ACADEMIA TODAY MAKE THEM OUT TO
BE.
THAT IS WHY THERE IS NO
ADVOCATES FOR SOCIALISM OR
COMMUNISM HAD ACTUALLY GREW UP
IN THOSE PLACES, WHO ACTUALLY
LIVED THERE.
THEY’LL COME HERE.
THE BOATS ONLY GO ONE WAY, SEAN.
BUT THE DNC WILL DO WHATEVER
THEY CAN TO TRY TO MOLD THAT
PERFECT CANDIDATE.
THE REALITY IS, THEY DNC IS NOT
IN TOUCH WITH ACTUAL REAL
AMERICA.
I DID 20 STOPS WITH KIMBERLY
YESTERDAY IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
IT WASN’T JUST THE PLACES WHERE
WE ARE GOING TO VISIT OUR
POSTERS.
COFFEE SHOP ALONG THE WAY --
>> Sean: GETTING LAZY.
>> GETTING A LITTLE SLOW.
NO ONE’S EVER CALLED ME
LOW-ENERGY.
THE ONE THING I’VE NEVER BEEN
ACCUSED OF FREIGHT >> Sean: I
BELIEVE THAT.
>>
IT WASN’T JUST OUR STOPS.
THE COPY SHOP ALONG THE WAY,
SOMEONE SEES YOU PULL INCOME OF
THREE BUSINESSES NEXT DOOR -- K,
YOUNG
, FEMALE ENTREPRENEUR, 22 YEARS
OLD UP AND PREFERS TO SHOP.
THEY ARE COMING OUT AND SAYING,
THANK YOU.
I AM ONLY ABLE TO DO THIS
BECAUSE OF YOUR FATHER’S
POLICIES.
THIS IS NOT THE COOKIE-CUTTER
THAT THE MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO SAY, THAT IS THE ONLY
PERSON BELIEVING IN TRUMP’S
POLICY.
IT WAS EVERYTHING BUT WRITE HALF
THE TIME I AM WONDERING MYSELF
BECAUSE THAT SORT OF
STEREOTYPE DOES LEAVE AN
IMPRESSION ON YOU, EVEN ME, AND
I AM SAYING, I’M NOT SURE WHERE
THIS IS GOING FOR A GROWN WITH
TEARS IN THEIR EYES BECAUSE THEY
ARE LIVING THEIR AMERICAN DREAM.
IT MAKES ME WANT TO FIGHT SO
MUCH HARDER, SEAN.